Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right. What's cool.
On guys.
This is Rob and we are picking back up again with DC and this is,
it's still like an amazing story while this is one you guys need to get out and
buy. Okay. So, so we pick up with the last video that we did, right?
And last video that we did focus on the idea that the various villains who
existed out there had basically recreated the amazing shows with Dr. Ivo, right?
Dr. Ivo was a guy who,
who originally created a main zone and he's essentially working for the
villains. Now, amazing is basically an Android,
but he essentially has the powers of the justice league.
And he's one of these guys where just one amazing can actually take out the
whole justice league. They have a whole army of them.
And one thing to keep in mind, the justice league,
as we think about it is like the traditional Superman, the traditional Batman,
and not to really knock on Jonathan Kent or Damian Wayne,
but there are no court Kent or, or Bruce Wayne respectively, right?
Like they're just not on the same level as their fathers.
And so what you're talking about is an army of, of [inaudible].
This is going to be taking on what is in effect,
a diminished justice league now for Oswald Cabo pot, right? For the penguin,
he's kind of impatient here. He's like, dude,
you promise us results a while ago. Right. It starts to off Ivo. And he's like,
look, man, like he basically like activates a few of these robots. He's like,
look, man, just one of these can take out the justice league.
What do you think they'll do to you?
And understand these guys went on programming. If I leave off a decimal point,
these guys will wipe out everything on the planet, right?
So I have to make sure this is programmed meticulously because remember the
whole idea of the villains is, is to wipe out the unliving,
but not for any kind of altruistic means it's because once the unliving are
wiped out,
they can in turn most likely turn the [inaudible] onto the superheroes,
take the superheroes out and then inherit the world for themselves. Right?
It's just kind of a circumstantial world. Domination is basically what it is.
Now. The other part of that,
what we ended up doing is we switched over to cyborg and then reality is a
little bit disappointing,
but it turns out that the life equation is inside cyborg and he basically
restructures or recodes his blood so that the life equation is confined within
his own genome. These are,
that I have with that is I was really hoping we would see white lanterns.
If I'm going to be honest with you guys,
I was really hoping we would see white lanterns because remember all the various
superheroes who made it off earth and are basically headed toward your group,
took off into space there with the green lanterns, right? Like don't forget,
the green lanterns are out there.
And all the other heroes are with the green lantern, the other heroes,
the surviving humans, they're all currently with the green lantern Corps.
But regardless what we end up having here is basically like this kind of
conversation, right? How do they get this out of them? Like how do they get the,
the life equation essentially out of cyborg?
And then turn it into something that can be used,
like synthesize it into a cure that can be given to people. Well,
Damian Wayne ends up having the idea to go see swamp thing.
And the reason why is not necessarily because of swamp thing,
but because of Alec Holland,
remember Alec Holland is the name of the guy who became swamp thing.
And he was a gifted biochemist, right? A biologist and a biochemist,
probably the best in the world before he became swamp thing.
And Damien kind of hits them up and says, look, man, like we need you, right?
Like we need the mind of Alec holon to help us solve this problem, right.
To help us solve this equation.
And initially swamp thing is a little bit hesitant,
not in the sense of he's just like, I never really liked Alex,
so I don't want to work with you. Right?
It's not like a Bruce banner incredible hook dichotomy.
It is one of these things where he's like, I can't do this on my own.
What you're asking me to do is not something that I can do myself. I mean,
I could, but not in the short period of time that you're looking for,
because what you're looking to do is to synthesize a cure as fast as humanly
possible and then spread it to the world. And while I am incredibly powerful,
I'm not powerful on that level. Right. And so when he is,
I'm saying what Damian Wayne did is actually concoct a plan exceedingly fast and
say, yeah, you're not going to be doing this alone.
And the way this works is actually pretty genius, right?
So you've got swamp thing here. You've got poison Ivy. You've got Dr. Fait.
You've got CyBorD, you've got, uh, detective Chimp. You've got Mary Marvel,
the new 52 while he was the young black Wally West. You've got a Harley Quinn.
You have all these people who were here because in some form or fashion,
they can basically help to synthesize this virus. Synthesizes cure much faster,
right? Mary Marvel's got wisdom. The cure is inside of cyborg.
Alec Holland is the mind of a, of a genius level, biochemist and biologist.
Dr. Fate,
who's there to basically unite the minds of all the people who are here. Uh,
poison Ivy was a doctor of toxicology.
Harley Quinn was a doctor of psychology and medicine.
And Wally West has the fastest mind on the planet. And then literally Tom,
Taylor's like, Batman's here because he's Batman. And.
The only explanation we get.
Because he's Batman, but essentially they're able to,
to kind of turn this into a cure that can be synthesized, right?
So it's only the first step. The next step is to actually mass produce it.
Right?
And so if you kind of get these diametrically opposing views and the sense of
Superman sets up and says, now we can save them all at the same time,
over in the layer of the villains it's now we can wipe them all out, right?
So they're literally creating two different means to cure the anti-life virus.
One depends on wiping out everybody that's infected.
And the other one is about basically saving people,
curing people who are infected.
And so with the amazing start ripping across right from their base operations
spreading outward like a plague,
killing everybody who's infected with unlike literally just spraying them down
with heat vision.
This kind of switches back over to the heroes who basically say, okay,
now that we've got the actual cure, we need a test subject.
And initially black Canary, or it gets really green.
Canary now wants to start with Oliver queen,
but you end up having a scot-free who's like, no, we should start with Barta.
And scot-free plays this incredibly smart, right? Because Dinah gets off.
She's like, why should we start with BARDA? Right. Why should,
why should we start with Oliver? And Scott is like, well,
here's the thing to think.
About Sila. Here's the thing to understand, see if something.
Goes wrong, then BARDA is probably strong enough to take it.
We shouldn't really risk all cleans life. I read that and I was like,
well-played scot-free.
Well played.
What will you end up doing is transitioning or at least kind of teleporting to a
busy, uh,
a life habitable planet this out there by alpha Centauri by just some star out
there. And we're, scot-free initially had Barta tied up.
She of course never left the planet, but she did escape her confines.
So at that point they were kind of concerned like where in the world could she
possibly be? And then she comes, crashing down on them, right?
Like immediately attacks scot-free. Now in that moment,
Superman grabs a syringe and stabs into, into Barta.
And then it's just a ticking clock, right?
Like at that point it's literally just the clock is ticking down, right.
Seconds and seconds and seconds. Like how long is this going to take?
And Barbara just keeps on going on the offense. Right.
Keeps on attacking and attacking and Superman. It's like, okay,
the cure doesn't work. Right? Like I've got to kill her. And Scott's like, no,
don't hurt her. And then she snaps out of it. Right? So the cure works.
The day is saved everybody. The day is saved. Right.
Everything's copacetic big BARDA has been saved. So over to John Constantine,
right.
Sitting in this room that only he can access in the tower of fate possibly be
attacked by the cloak of rag man. Right.
Because it's trying to take the soul of, of John Constantine.
And then here comes the tunnel and she is. Right.
Because she's just kind of like, what are you doing, right. Like,
why do you have a room here that nobody can find?
Why do you have the wizard staff? Right? The,
the wizard Shizam why do you have a staff and the spear of destiny and madams,
antidotes, crystal ball. Why do you have all this? Right.
You came back from this mission with Jason, Todd and Todd died,
but is this what he died for Z to grab you to grab some just stupid relics?
Because from the perception of, of Natana Constantine,
what did this whole mission,
just for the sake of saving these last bits of magic,
maybe not really having anything to do with them,
but just kind of collecting them, you know, for his own personal interest,
because that's really something that John Constantine would Duke do,
people into going on a mission that only he really cares about knowing they
would die, but not really caring. Right? Not really worrying,
not really worrying about it at all.
The funny thing about this is that with this door being blown open and no one
really being able to access it except for Constantine and apparently the Tauna,
because nobody was really supposed to know it was there.
She left the door blown open, right? When that happens, Constantine's like,
okay, you have no idea what you invited here.
Anybody can find this place inter the Phantom stranger, right?
Phantom stranger just comes walking in to give the Marvel fans perspective.
Imagine the watcher just shows up. That's when you know,
things are going to pop off and the Phantom strangers like you stole Madam
madams, editor's crystal ball, the path you're on, you cannot continue on this.
And the response of Constantine is, but if I go off this path,
the entire earth is going to die. Right. I've seen the future.
I know what will happen. The entire earth is going to collapse.
We're all going to be destroyed.
And there'll be nothing that we can do about it.
And it's one of these things where he's kind of being,
being chastised by fandom street. Right. He asks, uh, he has a ton of like,
has he told you what he's done? And she's like, no. And he's like, well, I mean,
he took bragged. Man's cloak.
He stabbed rom MACUSA with the spear of destiny in order to get the crystal
ball. And then he imprisoned Boston brand in the cloak of rag, man,
the toughest pitch. She's like, are you serious, man? Like these are allies,
right? These are friends,
people that we fought along with for years and years and years.
And you're going to turn on them like that. Like, why would you do that? Now?
If anything, all this shows is how dark things are, right?
How desperate things are that this has to happen. Now, from there,
you have Constantine who literally starts laying into the fandom stranger,
right? Like after what you did to get yourself doomed for all eternity. Right?
Because we can kind of go with the origin.
The Phantom stranger is basically Judas and he's the one that betrayed Jesus.
He's like, you're in turn, going to chastise me about the decisions I've made.
Fatal stranger gets, right? Since I'm flying into a wall and then Constantine,
brandishes the spear of destiny, which can kill the fandom stranger.
And it's like, go on, dude. If you want to play this game,
we can play this game. I promise you we'll die. Then suddenly out of nowhere,
ExtraGen pops. Right. And ed Trigon's like gone now, Oh,
at your gun and rise again, the form of man, right.
Changes back into Jason blood and says, Constantine, we're screwed.
And he's like, why? And he's like,
because Trigon's coming while he's going to be here in moments, right.
In moments, he's going to burst through that.
They're going to burst through the earth and all hell's going to break loose,
right? Hell is going to be coming with them. You know? And he's like,
and there's more on top of that. And he's like, of course,
because try going invading the earth is not enough.
What more could possibly be going on.
And he basically tells them what's going on with the amazing,
with the amazing spreading across the world.
Things are getting dire for the superheroes. Very, very, very, very fast, right?
Because on one side they have all the villains who've banded together and
launched this army of amazing hosts to spread across the world and kill all the
various people that they now have a cure for. On the other side,
they've got trigon, who's showing up here. Now let's be honest with ourselves.
The biggest threat out of all these things that we're facing right now is
obviously trigon, right?
Trigon's like the biggest threat they have to deal with right now.
But it's one of these things where it's like, which one do they choose?
If they choose try again,
then the appraisals are gonna just going to tear everything up.
So there's not really going to be anything anybody left to save,
but if they ignore trigon and they focus on the [inaudible],
there's not going to be anything left to save. Right? So like the earth,
all of them will all basically just be cleansed and destroyed and that'll be it
because remember Trigon's here because he's angry over the fact that these
individuals who are infected with the anti-life virus,
that they're not really living with, they're not really dead.
And they technically should be dead.
And because of the fact that they're not trying and feels robbed of their souls,
right.
He feels robbed the fact that he's not able to take those individuals and bring
them to his realm. Right.
So he's basically just showing up to kill them all to take their souls. Right.
Because they are in effect mostly dead. Right. Just not officially dead.
And so from there, they're like, okay,
like the heroes kind of band together and say, okay.
So like the only real option that we have here is to effectively synthesize a
cure and then spread that cure around the world, just like try it, right?
Because the amazeballs are governed by programming.
And if the amazings are governed by programming,
their program says they have to kill those who were infected with the anti-elite
virus. But if there is nobody infected with the anti-elite virus,
there'd be nothing for them to destroy.
They would just stop what they were doing and just kind of free flow. Right.
They would just stay there, either that,
or go back to their home base and just say like all the on life had been
destroyed basically because there is no one life anymore.
So they killed the ones that were there before all of them were cured.
The only way to really do this,
the only way to really pull this off is through a combination of the flash and
cyborg and really the flash more than anything else where he basically rolls
through and reads all these different books on how to produce or how to,
how to duplicate viruses or cures using that combined with the plasma cells,
from sideboards blood, the flashes abilities,
he was able to basically create 3 billion copies of the serum in moments, right.
Probably a, you know, an hour or two. But like around that time, you know, with,
within those moments, like tried in bus out in Paris, right?
Like immediately explodes in Paris. All these unlikes come flooding,
flooding towards them. And in 15 minutes, everybody in Paris is dead. Right.
The entirety of Paris is totally and totally destroyed.
Now I know for somebody like try again and you know,
this doesn't really seem like a huge grandiose thing,
but this is kind of the nature of DC comics.
You don't really see things like Marvel, right. And this was a Marvel story.
It would be like, you know, try gonna merge. And then within two seconds,
everybody in Paris was dead. Like that's not really,
that's not really realistic,
at least as realistic as you can get when it comes to comics. Right? I mean,
we're talking about a demon emerging from health off because people infected
with a digital virus aren't really dead. Right.
So how realistic could we possibly be here?
But in comparison between Marvel and DC, DC plays a more quote,
unquote realistic tone with her comics did Marvel does, right.
That's why things were a lot more toned down and not necessarily as fight of
fancy as Marvel gets. And so, because of that, try again, you know,
just kind of makes his way out of Paris. Now with that being the case,
Constantine goes and gets, doc goes and gets Dr. Peyton says, okay,
I need you to see what's in this room. When Dr. Fait goes into the room,
that Constantine always kept hidden.
He's met by ed trigon and the Phantom stranger and John Constantine putting on
the cloak of rag, man. And that's when Dr. Fait's like, okay, wow, okay.
This is bad. Like, things are really bad. If you've got trigon here,
you've got the Phantom stranger.
Who's basically this omnipotent omniscient guy who basically swears to never
interfere. Like things must be exceedingly bad here.
And that's what Constantine's like. Yeah. They are.
I'm going to need your ambulance and I'm going to need your help.
And Dr. Fait's like, that's not going to happen, man.
I'm not going to give you that. And that moment, Phantom stranger stabs Dr.
Fate, right? Just like plunges the spear of destiny right. Through them.
And what it's just kind of like, why did you do that? And he's like,
because Constantine showed me the future and you would stop him from doing what
needs to be done. Right. So we got to take you out. But the helm of Nabu,
which Dr. Fait wares can not be, just take it. Right.
It has to be relinquished freely. He has to basically give it to somebody.
And so consciously it's like, yeah, I'm well aware of that.
So we grabbed the spear of the wizard.
Shizam puts his hand to Dr. Fait's head and then shouts Shizam and all the power
of Dr. Fate transfers to John Constantine, which he in turn cakes,
the helm takes the ambulette and says time to go right now, inter Zatanna right.
She comes back in like, okay, what's going on? Like, you just took the power,
Dr. Fait, like what in the world is going on here? And Constantine's like,
I'm going to go save the day. Now the reality here that the,
of what Tom Taylor tells us is it doesn't look like Constantine's going to
survive, but it doesn't look like he's going to lift through, this is a Tonna.
Isn't told this, you know, she's like,
are you going to be able to come back from this? And he's like, of course,
it's me. Why wouldn't I be able to come back from that? Right.
But he doesn't actually say, yes, I'll come back. You just says, yeah, it's me.
Right. And so, because of that,
where he doesn't really give her a definitive answer,
it seems to me because she would try to stop him the question to ask you,
if he's armed with a spirit that can kill a God.
If he's armed with a magical power of Dr. Fait, which is comparable,
if not more powerful than the power of Dr. Strange,
if he's got the cloak of Rodman, right.
Which allows him to use all the abilities of anybody who's been ensnared within
the cloak is all of that going to be enough against a force light trigon.
I don't know. But with that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys are the sub button
to become part of the rod core. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and that we'll catch you all later.
Bruce.